welcome to the NewsHour turkey says it's
launched a renewed military operation in
northwestern Syria it follows the
killing of 34 Turkish soldiers in Syrian
government airstrikes in Idlib province
on Thursday
Turkey's defense minister says the
operation is in self-defense against the
Assad regime syrian state media says
turkey has shot down two Syrian
warplanes in an ad lib but the pilots
are safe
hache Barbara is our correspondent on
the turkey-syria border near hat a and
let's just begin with this very
confusing picture about planes either
being shot at or shot down well this
this is because of the series of reports
we've been getting over the last year
hours about spectacular spike of events
now in Syria particularly in the
province of Idlib
this is absolutely an indication of a
widened military confrontation taking
place at different fronts but let me
just explain exactly what's happening so
now from according to the Turkish
military of Defense earlier today
without specifying exactly where Syrian
fighter jets were planning to attack
Turkish warplanes and then the Turkish
warplanes had to retaliate shooting down
two Syrian fighter jets they said that
it also destroyed three defense
batteries in Italy province this comes
only almost two hours after the Turkish
defense ministry said that its military
operation a new campaign peace shield is
under way and they say that this
operation has started the night Turkish
soldiers were killed and they say that
it will continue in Italy province and
that they are determined to take
retaliatory retaliatory actions against
the Syrian government they said also and
that's according to the Turkish military
defense ministry they don't wish to get
into any confrontation with the Russians
but however
every action which is going to be taken
from our own words is going to be
considered as an act of self-defense
this is obviously an indication of an
escalation in different parts of Syria
particularly in the northwestern part
and of course we're seeing or hearing
more about a Syrian offensive in and
around Dara exactly so this is exactly
what is happening as this is further
increasing in Daraa province the Syrian
government has launched today an
offensive to take over the city of a
Sunnah - an amine has been a major
opposition stronghold that are widely
seen by the Syrians as the birthplace of
the 2011 uprising
however in 2017 when the Syrian
government backed by Russia started to
gain control they signed
reconciliation agreements with the
opposition one of those agreements was
about diffusing tension in a sauna main
that didn't work the government failed
to break build bridges and win the
hearts and minds of the people today
they said it's about time - to take over
the city but we getting reports from
activists that the fighting still
intensify over there but now if you go a
little bit further north towards the
south of Italy that's another
spectacular story happening rebels
backed by Turkey are taking over major
territory in in in settlement also in
the DeBellis area those gains would not
have been possible had it not been for
the massive Turkish support for the
Syrian opposition just a few days ago
they lost most of that territory
yesterday and today the manager came
back most of that territory so what you
seeing on the ground is clearly an
indication that the political military
map in Italy province is ever-changing a
cloth across the our Hashem thanks for
the update - Barbara there on the
turkey-syria border